this is the first part of a mini course
on differential privacy and statistics
which was put together by three people
such a slob commit who's going to speak
now and vishesh Karla but fortunately
couldn't make it and got some time out
to speak and so we're going to start
with a talk by Sasha giving us sort of a
statisticians perspective on mystical
inference privacy thank you John
it's good to be here so just to
reiterate so basically in the next block
of there will be roughly three thoughts
so the first one vishesh couldn't be
here so I I'm trying to relay or I guess
give you a sense of his in my
perspectives as statisticians on
statistical inference and privacy the
second talk we will be by bottom on
computer science perspective on imprints
and privacy and we'll give a few
specific examples and then the last talk
will focus a bit more on applications
and we'll talk about synthetic data and
Rachel Cummings who is here has
graciously agreed to help us out and
give a computer science perspective
specifically on on synthetic data okay
so my talk I will try to give you a bit
of a I guess a high level of you or some
sense of how some of us in statistical
statistics community think about
statistical inference given the privacy
constraints and I think what motivates
many of us to work on this problem is
what Cynthia twerk and John most
recently coined the Feinberg problem and
I will just quote what they said the
finder problem is it says how to give
federal unrestricted data access to
trusted and well-intentioned analysts
and permit him to safely publish his and
I added here word valid findings and
that idea goes back to beginnings of
some ideas that of differential privacy
and and I want to take a moment to
reflect on this
so first general privacy confidential
confidentiality has just relaunched in
December with with an issue in the
special of special honor of Steve
Feinberg for those who did not know
Steve he was a famous statistician he
passed in December of 2016
and he was one of the main actors and a
driving force really in bringing
computer scientists and statisticians
together in trying to address data
privacy problems and I was lucky that
actually in 2003 when Cynthia twerk
presented some of the initial ideas on
formal privacy differential privacy
Carnegie Mellon I was there and I
remember Steve saying right away after
she finished a presentation saying
something to the extent well you just
threw all the utility down the toilet
okay and and so but Steve was an
optimist and a visionary from my
perspective and along with Cynthia and
Kobe and and Adam was there at the time
as well there was a workshop that would
or that was organized in Burton ro Italy
in 2005 very much like this workshop the
intent was that was to bring the
computer scientists decisions and
practitioners together and for some of
you who were there there's a story that
has been retold many times the workshop
broke almost broke down on the second
day so no
bad juju here we are in the second day
so hopefully we know how her going to
handle that pad here so what happened
well statisticians thought that
cryptographers cryptographers were
paranoid we could really wish true we
couldn't really understand this
excessive worry about auxilary
information and exceptionally strong
adversary on the other hand the
cryptographers are really frustrated by
ad hoc news
that's the positions brought to the
table and at Harkness in the sense that
they wanted more formal privacy
definitions both in terms of a risk and
utility loss or statistical inference so
fast forward 15 years plus or around 15
years depending from which point you're
looking at here we are again a diverse
audience and we are still discussing and
trying to figure out this discussing the
same problem and trying to figure out
how we can find a common language and
the common ground but we did come along
and and there have been many many
improvements and movements in in this
direction okay
and so I will hopefully give you some
sense of that that I feel for me as a
statistician some of the notions that
that I was introduced to back in 2005
have mood moved me in a particular
direction in thinking about a data
privacy problem in statistical when it
comes to statistical databases so so the
way that I want to think about it and I
think about the finder problem is that
our ultimate goal is to share data under
now rigorous privacy guarantees so rigor
is coming now if you think from formal
privacy or differential privacy
perspectives but we also want to
maintain their utility for statistical
inference and I will
shortly define what I mean by
statistical inference and why is this
important well you know is a suspicion
as a practitioner you wanna encourage
reproducibility you want to encourage
with science we typically want to
combine multiple data sources and we
want to make data accessible and
available to users that otherwise they
would not have access to the data okay
in this process there is this risk
utility trade-off and specifically I'm
referring to a disclosure risk and for
some for some of us in in statistics
community we often like to think about
framework of differential privacy or
differential differential privacy
perhaps as a way to specifically define
disclosure risk as a measure of
disclosure risk okay and that requires
additional non-trivial amount of noise
we heard that yesterday from a number of
talks and this is the same idea that it
has existed in statistical disclosure
limitation literature since the 60s
which said you need to introduce
additional bias and variance into the
data however how you formalize that
that's what the difference has been for
the past you know 50 years 60 years in
statistics community versus what
computer scientists particularly
cryptographers has brought to the table
in making us think more rigorously about
the problem in these definitions okay I
didn't expect okay
and then the data utility basically asks
the question well what are the data
useful for and and more specifically can
we actually infer valid statistical
statistical inferences from these noisy
data because we know we're manipulating
them and we're not working with the
original data that we're used to if if
I'm a real practitioner animal survey
researcher right so so this is you know
the assumptions are that we're gonna
assume that we have some rigorous
privacy more
models we're adding non-trivial amount
of randomness and we're interested in
understanding what are the implications
mystical inference so to talk will focus
on how can we perform valid inference
under the constraints of form of privacy
models and how can we design the optimal
differential private mechanism and
inference procedures and hopefully I'll
I'll be able to explain what I mean by
optimal and I'll try to provide a 2.0 to
points of view from a theoretical
statisticians and it applies the
decision point of view okay and this is
rough I mean I I consider myself both
but I really consider myself more
methodologies rather than theoretical
supposition yeah so what is the physical
inference so no privacy I don't care if
there any privacy constraints what do we
do in statistics the the main objective
in statistics is you given some observed
outcomes some of their data
you won't infer what the data generating
process is so if I have set of records
that come from some distribution P that
could be a normal distribution let's say
we assume that income comes from another
distribution typically I observe a
random sample of individuals from my
underlying population but my inference
is all about the characteristics of the
underlying population so one way to make
that statistical inference is to say I
want to find my best guess estimate of
what the mean unknown what the mean
income is in the population going back
to the talk about statistical learning
from my perspective statistical learning
machine learning is also statistical
inference it's just a statistical
statistical inference that has a
different objective in mind okay the
focus is more on on prediction but there
you know and but you can you can think
of many different ways of how to
the inference would be depending on the
context that you're working with okay
most statistical inference tasks can be
identified as three types estimation we
talked about point estimation confidence
intervals and hypothesis testing these
are tools that any especially applied
researcher or cetacean will will work
with and I will focus on some of those
in the talk okay so then the next
question is also how to construct
optimal estimators and I'll get get to
that in a bit okay so I'm interested
about the quantities at the population
level I don't see really my population
what I see is a random sample and I use
a random sample to figure out my best
guess about quantity of interest in my
population and some very variation
around that best guess okay now what
happens when we introduce privacy
constraints I said earlier we are saying
that we're now going to add some
additional randomness so I still have
the random sample so I ran a survey of
hundred students who are applying to to
various Berkeley graduate programs at
Berkeley it's a graduate admission study
right now right and I add some kind of
noise through some privacy mechanism
this privacy mechanism could be
differential on the under the framework
of differential privacy could be
something totally different
such as synthetic data without
differential privacy okay it's it's a
privacy mechanism so and I'm saying here
from my perspective of privacy mechanism
then it simply is a family of
conditional probability distributions
that's what I'm denoting is Q Y given X
1 up to xn so now the private sample
space that I actually work with and that
actually
observe so I don't really observe this
space any longer if I'm the user I
actually observe this space now instead
of making inferences from this sample to
the population I need to make inference
from the private sample to the
population because I'm still interested
in figure figuring out the same
characteristic I'm still interested in
knowing what is the true average income
in this population of interest yes
correct by user yes correct by user I
mean those data data analysts okay
although one of them could be a data
analyst yes so here are you doing that
this wide surface of the same type as a
data set or goodbye we actually a
private estimate of theta itself so so Y
could be could be it could be an
estimator from the data it could be
their themselves like a synthetic data
or an under end of sample that's a great
question yes so it could be some measure
could be some statistic right I know is
a statistic or could be data themselves
that we introduced some additional noise
bias variance - okay and again I want to
make I'm trying to figure out the
privatised estimator
so this is what I said this is the goal
I still want to now estimate the same
quantity of interest in the underlying
population subject now that I have this
privacy model okay so here just to be
clear F is a set of all conditional
distribution that satisfies let's see
differential privacy please because
that's what I'm going to work with for
the rest of the talk okay so we have
seen this definition of differential
privacy yesterday I don't think I need
to go through this again so I'm assuming
the same definition so this is the you
know conditional distribution this is
kind of the mechanism just a different
labeling and the epsilon is the measure
of information leakage right what I do
want to bring out is that I think for
many superstitions we found the
following interpretation or differential
privacy quite useful so Wasserman Anju
Larry Wasserman Andrew and they had a
paper in 2010 in jhaza where they kind
of outlined their version of statistical
framework for differential privacy and
basically what they show is that one way
to interpret differential privacy is
that if you're interested in testing if
user is is part of the database or not
right this is hypothesis test
you basically have no power sophistical
power to do this okay because the power
is bounded by alpha e to the epsilon
epsilon is your privacy parameter and
alpha is the type 1 error typically
let's say 5% in most cases it could be
something else you can figure out what
it is so that's a very low value and I
think that type of interpretation for a
lot of citizens make sense right and I
think part of the the objective of this
workshop is for us to figure out how we
can communicate to each other about some
of these basic concepts okay what we yes
I'm just curious this is sort of a
perception psychology tech question
bound on the power and had the form
alpha plus Epsilon
do you think that it would be equally
convincing to the community I'm not to
use specifically but to the community at
large like does the form the
multiplicative form of the bound do you
think that registers is important well I
mean you know if the epsilon is not very
small which is what we aim for them it's
it's right but that's a good question I
mean I think if
so it's like the voice yeah yeah what is
a small I mean but so but I think this
is what I'm thinking about I mean here
we have seen applications where epsilon
is very big right so then I you know but
even even there's a sense in which you
know with one in a hundred is also kind
of super small flaw right yeah well I
think the reason why this is useful is
because of the way that you the the
original definition is defined right so
but you asking me why why we're finding
entirely a question about like
perception in the statistical community
yeah
if the form of that bound have been
slightly different yeah would anybody
care I mean I know is there yes I think
well okay so I so yes let me say yes and
now I think a practitioner right to whom
you're saying that the power of
identifying that person is very
extremely low wouldn't care I think for
theoretical a statistician is if you you
know depending what you what balance you
need to derive like if we talk about
minimize bounce and other suboptimal
properties maybe you you will you would
care what the form is does that help
yeah yeah that's that's fine I mean that
is I think an interesting discussion
therefore that I mean I'm not sure that
yeah so as a statistician the first time
I saw my height did not go to the mall
looking to perform it was the e right
like why is why the hell but it's not
the alpha plus Delta or alpha times
Delta I'm not sure I would have cared
that much about that device right
whereas I mean there are mechanisms that
are kind of clearly horrible that
satisfy the additive bound it was just
picking anyway sorry stitches in the
wrong so it's like doesn't matter okay
so the other properties that are nice
we've already heard about this I'm not
gonna go into it just so that you know
we are aware of this and it is
appreciated the composition it's a great
thing because it says we can have
multiple releases and we understand how
to break down that potential privacy
budget given the multiple releases
robustness to the post-processing is
good again this idea of that you can
quantify the privacy budget of course
there's a whole separate question of
what the privacy budget ought to be and
transparency is really really important
this is something that the fact that
differentially private mechanisms are
transparent throughout you know exactly
what type of noise you adding and when
you're adding that is actually also very
important for statistical inference and
I have to say that many of statistical
methods they were developed up to now
even somewhere still in use in many of
the agencies they clearly lack
transparency so Kobe mentioned yesterday
swapping and and we said well you know
we know they swap but we don't know what
the percent small percentage of swapping
is or you perturb the records you don't
know what the perturbation is or you
hide the cells we know statistically
that you're hiding them you're gonna get
missing data they're not missing in
random but you have no idea what the
missing mechanism is that is really
going to affect your inference so this
is what's the decisions in the audience
right so this transparency is really
important okay
so so basically if we're going to work
with differential privacy and we add in
this additional randomness we need to
think about how how do we still maintain
valid inference and does that mean that
we have to modify the existing methods
do we have to come up with new methods
because ignoring the noise will lead to
invalid inferences and particularly in
finite samples okay and so I'm gonna use
one simple example to demonstrate this
and I think Galton will spend quite a
bit more time specifically in the
hypothesis testing showing some
differences how this affected the
inferences so why confidence intervals
so I said earlier the basically the
three key inferential tools that we all
think in statistics about and start from
point estimation confidence intervals
and hypothesis testing so confidence
intervals in addition to the point
estimator which just gives you the best
guess of the of the quantity of interest
we are always interested in capturing
uncertainty about the quantity of
interest right so confidence interval
quantify uncertainty in parameters and
confidence intervals you know this is
one way of want to find an uncertainty
there building blocks for almost all of
our methods that we develop being
parametric nonparametric the linear
regression causal inference if you think
about the applications one example in in
statistical disclosure limitation of
course where confidence intervals have
discussed a lot are where with this idea
of verification servers so the idea is
that user doesn't have access to the
original data user has access to the
data analysts I should say data analysts
has access to let's say some synthetic
data or some perturb data but they want
to make sure that the the results
they're getting correspond to what they
would have got if they had access to the
original data so verification server
will basically then spit out the output
and say
here is the confidence interval and how
it overlaps on the original data versus
the synthetic data or the manipulated
data and of course it's been shown that
giving those type of confidence
intervals compromise privacy and there's
work that I didn't cite here most
recently by people at Duke who are
looking also to provide for example
differentially private outputs from the
verification servers or they're looking
in those type of problems okay so how do
we can we do well the confidence
interval under the constraints of
differential privacy what is the
confidence interval I will in a minute
so I mean I'm not gonna go too much into
detail so I'm gonna zoom that data a
random sample let's say from a normal
distribution center that mean mu and
variance Sigma squared I'm gonna assume
the Sigma squared is known this is like
the simplest hook inference problem in
statistics and I will also assume that
the mean has some unknown range
okay the parameter is unknown ray sorry
but it's bounded and we want to
construct one minus alpha level epsilon
DP confidence interval from you okay so
what is what does it mean in terms of
non privacy so without privacy the best
interval it will be centered at the best
guessed estimate of your mu so in this
case like sample mean plus or minus some
variability that comes from the sample x
this value here Z Z with the subscript
alpha half and that is related to this
coverage that you want to have of this
interval so alpha if you do the typical
example alpha is 5% right so here I'm
gonna look at values of Z from the
standard normal distribution I'm looking
the probability disease great
some value and that has to be equal to
0.25 or the probabilities here in the
edges okay so this is my confidence
interval on that normal distribution
right okay and so the length of the
interval here is 2 Sigma as divided by
square root of n times this is Z alpha
have 95% confidence interval is the most
common one I can have a 90% confidence
interval I can have 99% confidence
interval this is all about how confident
you want to be about your estimation or
how much error you're willing to to
produce type 1 and type 2 errors false
positives in folding false negatives
okay so what we want is to produce the
honest and small as possible
differentially private interval in a
minimax sense so what do I mean smallest
well I want to have for every end I want
my coverage to be 1 minus alpha okay so
that's really what I want and smallest
is because I want to have the the best
or the soundest Punk inference that I
can in in this particular setting ok so
can we do something simple so I have the
data I have here the bound on the data
that's required I'm going to use the
Laplace mechanism so I didn't define the
Laplace mechanism but briefly here we'll
so you add noise from the Laplace
distribution that is proportional to the
global sensitivity and in this case I'm
going to truncate data x1 up to xn and
they lie in this bounded data space and
I'm getting here t1 to Etienne's so
these are truncated values right from
some triquet it space so I'm going to
compute truncated mean so instead of
x-bar which is using all the data
without any truncation now I'm computing
the truncated mean I have the global
sensitivity of truncated mean to be
divided by n ok and I'm gonna add noise
to this trimmed mean as Z where Z is the
plats noise with mean 0 and the standard
deviation 2 times global sensitivity
divided by
Epsilon and I'm gonna out output that
noisy mean so this is taking an optimal
procedure in statistics and trying to
make it in a simple way differential in
private so how does it work and what
does it do
of course how do I assess is this a good
thing to do well I wanna also use this
confidence intervals perhaps to do
hypothesis testing and I am interested
in also understanding what is the
sampling distribution of Y bar so there
are three approaches here I'm going to
consider three types of sampling
distributions I'm gonna ignore the noise
so I'm gonna take the Y bar and pretend
like this is the original like it came
from the original sample I'm gonna
incorporate the noise the variance of
the noise in the Y bar so the variance
from the noise from the Laplace
mechanism and then I'm gonna derive and
also an approximate sampling
distribution of Y bar so I'm gonna do an
additional approximation okay so I'm
gonna look at these three distributions
so this is a distribution sampling
distribution of the sample mean ignoring
the noise so notice the values here on
the x axis here is the sampling
distribution of the noisy Y bar sampling
mean when we actually take into
consideration that the noise was added
from a plasterer bution so see the
effect here that I am definitely
changing the variance right and then I
can also use that I can do a convolution
basically I can use the normal applies
approximation so here I have
approximately Laplace by normal here I'm
actually doing the full-on convolution
normal in Laplace so I'm still calling
it approximation and I get a slightly
different variance okay if I want to do
hypothesis testing I'm gonna use this
sampling distribution for hypothesis
testing so let's say that I'm interested
in knowing
- Lincoln mu is equal to zero and I can
compute p-values er I'm sampling here
yes yes maybe or even one more side back
like three approaches and your goal is
to do what to produce the cut of the
confidence interval that is the one that
holds the actual mean with probability
one - yes I want I want honest I want
honest and small as possible interval
right so honest is I want the coverage 1
- alpha for all possible ends and for
all Mew yes but I'm not saying this is
the good thing to do like I'm not saying
this is the procedure to do it I'm not
sure I even understand why oldest we are
well the first one was it honest and the
second they are not so my goal is that
this is what I want so I'm starting and
Sam I'm gonna take a naive approach here
because I don't know any better because
I have an optimal I have non-private
optimal procedure that I know how to
construct a confidence interval right so
now what I want to do I'm gonna I know
I'm adding noise and the noise has been
added so so let me explain why I'm
showing you this big pause because if I
so so let me back up in statistical
disclosure limitation we've been
producing perturb the noisy outputs for
a very long time I should say agencies
have been doing this for a very long
time and they actually did add noise to
data okay and they were sharing these
with users in no situations and almost
the problem in all situations user
always treated those data as the
original data
so that's this from my perspective
adding noise from Laplace distribution
or Gaussian or something else
I'm adding noise right to the statistic
of course here it's under more well
designed mechanism I'm adding noise if
I'm an outside user I'm very naive I'm
gonna take those that summary value and
I don't know any better I'm just gonna
use it believing that's my original data
does it make sense I mean this is this
is important right because there are a
lot of people I mean we've been doing
this for many years and specifically and
I want to demonstrate that with
differential privacy at least we have a
way to account for this in a right way
that will actually give us the right
confidence interval right well this this
is gonna be I'll explain yeah this this
is going to be this is this particular
case I'm actually gonna get a very I'm
gonna get a very short interval right so
it's gonna be a problem with some other
case in case is I'm actually gonna get
something that's streaming wide which is
also not good for inference purposes so
so let me let me get to that I was gonna
make the point with this is it clear
what I was doing here why the left
option is I understand that the he
chooses making this work is absurd to me
why this is part of a statistical
analysis I mean
I am NOT a nave user but I am NOT your
only audience I'm not your only customer
right many practitioners are their data
users they're your customers or our
customers I should say so my point is
that I'm showing this first of all to
demonstrate that this is a bad thing to
do to ignore the noise right
and to say that we actually need to
relay this message to the users because
a lot of questions that that we're
getting from the users these days
they're saying they're hearing about
changes at the census that are happening
right and saying all census is going to
produce synthetic data sense it's gonna
add to produce differentially privates
out outcomes right the statistics and
they're freaking out and they're saying
you're gonna ruin all my inference right
going back to Steve's utility is going
down the drain because they understand
how to account for that extra randomness
and that actually we can account for the
extra randomness so there's there's an
educational aspect here that we need to
reach out to a particular audience right
that that again going back to I don't if
it's easier to understand I preserve the
data or I suppress the cells in a table
right and I gave you a table with with
with what we call Swiss cheese right
these data are not missing and random
are the users analyzing this data have
been treating them as missing at random
this is the same thing they basically
are completely ignoring the noise
mechanism and that is wrong and this has
not gone away this is still a problem
right so I think that that's why I was
trying to bring this up any other
questions when n goes to infinity we
should swallow
okay here we go
so yes so and I'm interested in finite
sample inferences right and what does it
mean n goes to infinity how large does
it n need to be right that's an
important questions which you guys are
looking for sample complexity we are
also looking at that question right
trying to come up with is like
multiplying factors to adjust for this
noise so so here I thought through these
p-values that this is maybe a more clear
so I'm producing p-values and assuming
the null distribution is true given the
null distribution is true
the p-value should have a uniform
distribution so here is the non-private
case these vary by sample size 10 right
10 sample size and you know not ten
billion hundred thousand ten thousand
right and it's so forth so looks pretty
good reason will be uniform right what
you want that your box plot is showing
quartiles right yeah okay and and and I
wanna also to show that this is you know
symmetric it's roughly you know this is
all uniform here it's looking great so
what's happening here this is the one
where you naively ignore the noise this
is what you're asking me about like so
first one there's no noise this is the
original one right so but I'm resampling
here right this is a simulation so there
is some random is from sampling that I'm
doing right okay so here's where I'm
ignoring completely the Laplace
mechanism i'm Norrington oiz this is
horrible right and speaking of and goes
to infinity I mean here is n what is it
I will become 200,000 I'm still not
doing that well right and this is the
simplest problem in statistics yeah so
that the way that you're getting these
p-values you here assuming you know this
yes this is why this has been pushed to
the extremes yes yes
I'm assuming again the whole problem is
the simplest possible problem in creates
being pushed to extremes because I'm
assuming I know Sigma yeah okay when we
don't know Sigma then these things can
be addressed as well but I was trying to
use the simplest example now here is the
way your normal approximation normal
applies we're starting to do better but
these are basically the cases where now
we're explicitly try to account for the
noise that the mechanism introduced to
the original data and so we are doing
better so it's important to have a
transparent mechanism to be able to
account for the bias and variance that
we are introducing to the original data
if you want to get the right inference
normal applause yeah this is this is the
convolution and here I'm approximating
Laplace by the normals it's kind of
normal normal that's what I mean by
approximation point 25 point 75 yes II
did do better because we actually are
accounting we are counting for for some
additional noise in the right way so
it's kind of like taking care of some
also a randomness here okay so the
problem is ignoring noise can lead to
invalid tests invalid inference so in
the first case I'm getting narrow
confidence intervals right so will not
lead to the good inference so let me I
think I'm need to probably am I looking
at a time and so the the what basically
what we're talking about it that one
solution here is that we need to
incorporate distribution of the noise
into the procedure that we're doing if
you want to get the right inference and
there's a new paper by weighing it all
this is work from Daniel Kieffer and
actually vishesh
they actually provide some results and
asymptotic arguments as to when the the
asymptotics keep kicking and when it's
actually sufficient to do just
asymptotic inference I'm sorry I this is
also these paper also just came out in
this issue in jpc okay now variance of
noise air did is linear to B and if you
remember B is the range on the data
right and so this is the standard error
of that Laplace during a variable that
we are adding noise to and this is the
standard deviation from the sample
statistics just from a random sample
okay so B is the bound on the data right
so here the point that we want to make
is the choice of B is also crucial okay
so if you take small B you're gonna
truncate and you're gonna add bias if
you take very large B so you really you
know I take a wide range for your data
then you're going to add a lot of noise
in the air you're gonna increase the
variance and in finite samples that can
be very very important because they're
examples that I think we stretch with
meanshe's work with this allele I don't
know if I recall the heads in paper but
he said that in some cases you know
given this choice is the the the
confidence interval would be like 16
times larger then we're really supposed
to be to a practitioner right that's a
useless confidence interval I can't make
an inference if that is too wide either
yes we isn't be based on
how can you choose the I mean if your
data is ages then you know you can't say
yeah you wanna have it be 25 to 75 days
so that I think that's that's a separate
question I mean the the the one thing
also the differential privacy assumes
that you actually have to someone have
to have some boundaries on the data so
you can in some cases you can also
transform the data so it gives you some
natural bound in some cases given I
guess some prior information you can
decide what the bound is but you will
have to account for that as well
you know differentially private away if
you want to hold procedure to be
differentially private supplied by the
user yeah so if you know it's like this
wouldn't be private to be is like the
actual range of the data but there are
another approach there other there are
the approaches where you could yes but
again it's the simplest case this is the
B is provided Thanks
so I won't go into this you can read a
paper by V session what on so they're
basically saying we have a way of
figuring out or figuring out what a
nearly optimal confidence interval is
okay and there they eliminate the
dependence and the standard deviation of
the noise on B and they make no
assumption of the range of the data also
in the in there procedure which is
important and they basically have
minimax lower bounds on the length of
the intervals so plot numb is maybe
gonna mention some of this so I'm not
going to go into the details on this
okay so interval estimation with no
invariants and in essence I think what
they do it's a two-step algorithm so now
they're gonna look actually the range of
MU I said were looking at the range of
data but again that that's Gotham is
gonna I think talk about it so I don't
need to get into details on that I'm
just going to show here that what's
important is that this is the length of
the confidence interval the differential
private confidence interval
and you see a clear understanding of
what comes from the random sample and
what comes from from from the mechanism
very very very important this is really
what I only thing I want to say about
the slide very important for the
inference to understand how to separate
these things basically in order to model
the noise that that we get from from the
new individuals so estimating confidence
intervals ignoring the noise leads to
invalid Kaveri coverage this basically
what the sampling distributions that the
p-values were supposed to show and if
you are very careful and you can define
well with the privacy mechanism is and
what the ran normal distribution or what
the distribution is in our case a normal
distribution then we can account for
that in in the right way and so this
idea how to perform a lis the inference
counter generalizes okay so what really
really want to do is we want to treat
the if gamma here is basically you use
the privacy mechanism and gamma is the
the parameter of the of the privacy
mechanism we want to treat it as a
nuisance parameter so in statistical
inference the problem that I didn't show
I assumed nu is the parameter we're
trying to make inference about Sigma I
assumed is known often Sigma is not
known so in many cases if I'm not
interested in Sigma I can treated as a
nuisance parameter and I will find ways
of integrating it out or doing something
with it okay so this is the same thing
that so this is one of the principles or
ideas from statistics so I want to
integrate this mechanism out so I'm
going to now work with this marginal
likelihood and it's this distribution
that I'm going to use to find my point
estimates to do the confidence intervals
to do hypothesis testing but and this is
different from my P you know my
probability distribution that I begin
with from this one okay so instead of
working with this one to do my inference
now this is the distribution that I'm
working with to do my inference because
in that I accounted for
the mechanism ours it's not this is
generalization okay I was trying to give
an example with a black to the
confidence intervals and I'm saying this
generalizes I don't care what these
privacy mechanism is right it will work
for anything like this this is a basic
principle basic idea as long as I
understand the parameters of the privacy
mechanism yes I will get to that yeah
okay great great question right here
okay
so nu is an important object for valid
inference and a certain quantifications
right so it's a marginal likelihood okay
so let me just say with that this is
what I said earlier I can compute the
estimates I can compute the posterior
distribution I can generate the
synthetic data from this distribution
there are many many tasks I can do with
this okay
compute confidence interval but marginal
likelihood is often intractable this is
what you are referring to so of course
then we have to do some approximation to
the marginal likelihood this is still
very much an open problem from our
perspective we have worked on it in
couple of problems and other people have
worked on it here a couple of references
but we need to do better but from our
perspective there again like to
principle approach to attack this one is
to look at from the measurement error
modeling approach okay so this is often
applicable when there is a sufficient
statistic I mean in your model if there
questions about what's the future
statistic is I can explain in a bit if
it's of interest I want to get through
some of the slides the other one is to
find a surrogate or missing data
likelihood
okay so approximate M by sub surrogate M
and this is where some MCMC variational
in fair inference or bootstrap type
methods come into play so the whole
point is that we are trying to find the
best approximation to this marginal
likelihood and
can we get the good final sample
performances this is a cool you know
find that sample performance in this
case this is also a question it's well
known that you know asymptotes here is
nice but again here I don't if I talk to
froakie
many of her colleagues will work with
the random sample of five hundred
thousand if I'm a clinical trial it
could be 30 people right those are very
different numbers from from looking at
extremely large numbers here and this is
basically a ratio of the private and on
private confidence intervals that
Fisher's produced and basically just
showing you without going into details
here that you know very large sample
sizes this is four trimmed mean Trina's
asymptotic means and the medium boots
like we're you know takes a while for
the asymptotic show in this particular
case decay can and in many real
applications the the sample size is much
smaller so so that's one way we're
thinking about what are some of the
principles that we should be statistical
principles that we can use to do some
valid statistical inference under
privacy constraints then the second
question is can we design optimally
differentially private mechanisms and
inference procedures so we saw that with
the add Laplace noise there was sub
optimal so you you will you know you can
potentially add less noise by adding a
differentially private estimator arrange
of the data we want mechanism there was
designed perhaps to optimize over all
possible DP mechanisms so we won't want
some kind of uniformly most powerful
mechanisms or outcomes okay and relate
to this there is something that of
course in the binomial case a student of
mine and I have worked on so we derive
uniformly most powerful differentially
private binomial tests and p-values so
this is overall mechanisms we also have
extensions for confidence intervals and
couple of other things
and I think with them Gotham is also
going to bring that up okay so as is the
decision how do we think about how do we
design an optimal estimator again
without privacy and this is a very
simplified view theta is the true
parameter of interest theta hat is some
kind of estimator of that this is a loss
function the basically measure some
distance between the data and the theta
hat risk is the average loss function
over that distribution probabilities
tribution p we also assume we have some
kind of model which is a collection of
all probability distributions and so we
need a single summary to now compare
these risks and two most common ways
that we do this in statistics is to you
know find a minimax estimator or base
estimator in order to figure out what
what is the the best estimator so this
kind of gives you a sense of how why or
how do statisticians think about
devising best estimators or what I call
them designing best estimators and I
think some of the same principles should
hold even if you have privacy
constraints okay what is the loss
function I think what many of you are
familiar with the point I want to bring
out here is that I can have a mean
squared loss right in that case the the
risk is the mean square error in the
hypothesis testing my loss could be some
trade-off between type 1 and type 2
error okay
instead estimation the loss could be the
length of the confidence intervals so
there many different loss functions that
we consider
how and when do we consider which loss
function also depends on the problem
right so prediction or point estimation
doing mean square loss probably good if
I think about causal inference or
combining many estimates like a values
across many clinical trials they're
having unbiased estimators is really
important so there I maybe want to think
about a slightly different loss function
that I want to consider rather than just
using the mean square why is it
important at this point in this case
because you have many different sources
and you have to average over all of them
and and it's hard to kind of know how
how bad you if they're all and bias how
to account for that
so you aim for combining many estimators
a yes in causal inference you may also
have a multiple estimators depending on
a problem because you have the the
counterfeit Church of contra factual's
right what would have stolen causal
inference the typically care about
unbiased estimators so and I mean
I don't know if I can take a good
example right now okay um ask me after I
think about and so that's the point here
I mean this is just a repeat so in this
case we can work with this marginal
right likelihood and again the point
here now is that the risk is not to
respect to P anymore the risk now is
respect to this marginal like my
marginal likelihood that we have derived
but we can still use the same tools it's
just a different space that we're
working with okay I'm gonna skip this my
point this is going back to the earlier
point that it could be an estimate it
could be synthetic data there's really
not much difference here so we can
design differentially private mechanism
or any private mechanism or sometimes
the private mechanism is giving to us so
if I want to design the private
mechanism I can think about
give me a loss function give me the
family probability distribution
give me family of differential private
mechanisms or conditional distributions
that satisfy some differential
differential privacy what is the best
pairing of Q and theta hat that's I am
designing okay observational I can say
hey John is already produce the
differentially private or I'm sorry adam
has already produced a differentially
private mechanism to release a median
okay well because you're talking about
the medium yesterday right so now given
that given that you gave me that noisy
median right I want to find the best
theta hat which is what we're talking
about and you can mix these to design an
observational setting here the Q could
be differentially private synthetic data
and I can do many different things with
that so
so there are some connections to
algorithm design design of experiments
and surveys here thinking about a priori
what we want to do in designing things
back in 2009 and actually had a workshop
at IBM in 2010 I talked about these
factors for adjusting sample sizes and
activity we talked about a clinical
trial and I said listen you want to
design a clinical trial you know
typically what type of hypothesis you
want to test I can introduce privacy
into the design process at the onset I
don't have to wait at the end to
introduce the privacy right and I
remember at that time you know I was
talking about sample sizes of 10 and 20
and 30 and Cynthia at work said wait
that's not what we're doing we you know
we need a bigger size using in millions
right but we're here we're dressing
these type of problems so that's I think
a great leap it's very important ok
and both views will be useful again
agencies census is designing some
differentially private mechanisms right
now so these values are these issues are
important ok oh and here the question is
what should you be designed for what
class would be what class of loss
functions I hate to say it maybe this is
better phrase now than it was in 2005
but we we had the same type of
conversations and the questions in 2005
basically if you recall the workshop
we're still asking who are you designing
for what are we designing for what are
the models that people want to fit and
if you keep asking us like how do you
know and we're back at this again and in
some cases you have to think a priori
what are the potential uses of this data
I think it's really hard to get away
from this ok
so differential privacy mechanism
introduced additional noise we want
valid inferences we need to model that
additional randomness we claim that
prints basic principles for measurement
error literature and missing data
mechanisms and literature and statistics
can be utilized in in this case you know
this is
obvious at this point they simple
Laplace mechanism may not be optimal in
many cases and and we do have to
actually think very carefully about
designing algorithms and inferences
procedures for each inference tasks
especially in if you're thinking about
finite sample performance ok great
it is gonna work give me a second let me
wrap up and you can ask questions you
don't mind more realistic picture I had
physical model random sampling but then
there is always something else right
data collection cleaning exploratory
analysis model fitting model checking
interpretation of the results right here
is your super population final
population random sample this is where
all kinds of measurement errors and
missing data issues come in so and
applies to decision do I care about data
quality right
drunken junk out so I really need to
make sure my data have some integrity ok
so I worry about measurement error
missing values sample bias is structural
zeros and I suspect the fry okay we'll
talk about some of these issues ok we
still do really do not know how to end
to address many of these there's some
work on structural zeros etc but in
general I think we're pretty far away
from addressing these problems lot of
effort goes into modeling sources of
uncertainty to get valid inference
especially for first I would say survey
statistics model estimation every model
estimation we always think about
parameter estimation hypothesis
confidence intervals so you really could
not get away from that not only
specifications right I assumed my normal
model was the correct model right I
could be wrong we typically assume model
is never true only approximations right
we know the census is dealing with a lot
of hierarchical data at these days and
issues that come from that model
checking model selection etc so how do
we perform all of these in some kind of
privacy-preserving way that's a very
general very open question but pick any
of these
highlighted words and there's a problem
to be worked on okay
optimal location epsilon so that that's
a whole thing so I'm just gonna wrap up
with with this Alice lied so in ideal
world we want to give access to data to
trust them all intentional and honest
and permit him to safely publish valid
findings so I want Mawlid confidence
intervals point estimates I want valid
hypothesis tests at least okay so so
that I'm gonna I guess I'm over my five
minutes okay so so so in this is so I I
am I've used the confidence interval as
an example of thinking about how we can
do valid inference under privacy
constraints and how we can potentially
design valid mechanisms right so valley
Salil tell me my rename him
Salil and n vishesh have designed a
differentially private mechanism that
gives nearly optimal confidence
intervals right that's a design a
question and so of course that fits in
here they had some loss function in mind
and their loss function was so when I
say here you you specify a loss you
specify probability family probability
distribution you specify a family of
conditional distribution of the privacy
mechanisms and the laws there for them
they wanted the coverage of the
confidence image world to be smallest
there was a specific loss that I define
slides earlier right so it fits my point
is that what we're trying to say here is
that this is a more from our perspective
this is a more general framework of
addressing many of these problems and I
only used confidence interval to
demonstrate it but you know I can talk
about uniform the most powerful binomial
test that Jordan and I have done right
which basically does the same thing
we're designing this with a very
specific criteria in mind we want the
uniformly most powerful test that's
important statistics it's the classical
results it's a neyman-pearson result so
we want to see can we have that same
result under differential under privacy
constraints and we work with
differential privacy and I think this is
another way that you can convince
especially applies to the stations
because they're you know are
practitioners they're familiar with that
they're already familiar with a set of
tools so they're there two things you
need to convince them that this is
nothing to be scared of that there are
ways that you can actually do the right
inference with this and then you also
have to provide in the right tools to do
the right inference in some cases it is
easiest if you can build off of
something they're already familiar with
there may not always be the most
feasible or the best way to proceed
all right so not not all optimal
non-private procedures can suddenly
become optimal DP under DP
sorry okay I'll be back yeah yes uh-huh
[Music]
you know so yeah right Assam probably
relative efficiency in things like that
yeah okay I understand what you asking
so um you probably don't feel like what
I'm going to say but I think there is
value to both right I think it's
important for example I'm gonna go back
again we have a UMP in a binomial
setting I understand there's a paper but
Kobe saying that's probably the only
place you can get that such a result I
don't know we have to do for me all I
have to do understand he's paper will be
more and then do some more analysis so I
think there is we should be pursuing
this from both directions right one is
that if we can get such results such
statements that you have something
you're the most powerful most efficient
right unbiased the minimum variance
estimates and things like that right
because that means that you are adding
less noise if it's a minimum variate
something if it's unbiased writer I know
statistically what that means when I do
my confident when I do my inference that
that language means something to me on
the other hand there's massive
literature in statistics and robust
statistics right and there are many
cases where even without privacy we
cannot achieve such results right so I
think it's quite natural to consider
situations like that as well and think
about from a robust perspective I don't
know Matthew maybe has also something
more to say he works also in more
complex data like functional data and
high dimensional cases right so
a kind of computer Lewis says under
different writers you don't have
efficiency in general or or like the
notion of efficiency she majors for
finite samples they're kind of something
like that I don't think I don't I don't
know yeah yeah yeah same problems we do
yeah item Adams so that's radically a
efficient so this um p result that we
have that's for finite samples so i
can't say in general it doesn't exist so
it already exists for an example right
for one setting you should take the be
they're important questions so thank you
[Applause]